in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Reid
and Lydia are with us hey guys how are
you pretty good great
welcome welcome and where you guys from
we are from Dayton Ohio welcome to
Nashville thanks for stopping by how can
I help today so we recently paid off our
house yay yeah as young as you are old
are you - I'm 22 23 okay that's
ridiculous how do you pay off your house
a 23 years old
by following Dave Ramsey's plan how much
is the house worth the house right now
is probably worth 75 to 80 how did you
do that I got to know before you ask
your question
we were both natural savers growing up
we've been working since we were 15 16
and we've just stockpiled our money away
and put a little toward the house and
once we got married we both had a lot of
savings so once we got married we just
basically you know lived on bare
necessities we both drive crappy cars
yes decision 23 years old you paid for
house my god yeah rattleball yes sir
it's awesome you're gonna be so wealthy
very cool it's awesome man you know
you're incredibly weird I love it thank
you there's there's kind of a little bit
of a story that goes with that
okay so we we bought the house a year
after we got married we rented for a
year we bought a house and then exactly
two years to the exact date June 1st we
paid we made the last mortgage payment
and there was it wasn't even planned a
couple days later we were looking back
and we realized that it was exactly to
the day that I was 2 years and that same
month we got pregnant all right
it was just it's amazing how God works
so absolutely so I bet your parents are
both just thrilled they are well that's
amazing okay they instilled a lot of the
principles that you teach in us though
yeah there's no one you get there at 23
years old accidentally right wow that's
awesome I'm proud of you guys okay yeah
so now I got the picture and your
household income is what um this this
past year is probably about 80 oh my
gosh you're just in great shape okay how
can I help I don't know if I can I think
you're already on your way but how can I
help
so our question was we both were
interested in doing rental property
so we wanted to know where to invest
that money while we're saving for it
short-term got a car with like five
years yeah well I mean the answer that
if you use mutual funds if you leave it
alone less than five years there's an
increased chance of that of the market
being down right when you want to buy
something right like for instance let's
say you'd put money in in September it'd
be down right now because the market is
slick you know in the short term here
but I'm not worried about that
on the long term so five years out you'd
be fine so you know my Dave Ramsey
answer from a safety standpoint is I
don't tell people to invest in mutual
funds unless they're gonna leave it
alone at least five years which would
leave you with nothing to do except
something horrible like a money market
account which is so what I did is I've
done a combination of those two things I
have a pile in the money markets and
then I'll do I'll take some risk that it
might not be up when I'm ready to buy a
piece of real estate and I just use a no
Commission no-load fund an index like an
S&P 500 fund they're kind of a
no-brainer because they do just what the
market does so you're going to make a
whole lot more on average a whole lot
more than you make on a money market
account I'm Lee market accounts paying
like 0.8 right so and you know the stock
market averages around twelve years so
it would have to be like 1/12 as good to
be down there but sometimes it can be
actually backwards so you could lose
money so the thing is you've got to be
willing to accept that risk and so let's
say that you're making $80,000 a year
you start popping 30 grand in that thing
in a year okay as an example I just made
that up I'm not suggesting it but you
know you could put thirty thousand
dollars in there you could look up and
twelve months later it could be worth 28
as long as you're willing to accept that
right on the average I think you'll come
out I personally use an S&P 500 fun when
I'm marking money to get ready to buy
real estate because because I'm but I'm
willing to take that fluctuation ride
knowing it might be down right about the
time I want to buy some real estate I
might take a hit but on average I think
I'm going to come out okay
and the truth is over the period of
years I've been doing it I've made a lot
of money on those SP funds while waiting
to buy real estate with them so but it
just depends on what you know the other
thing is how the longer you're going to
leave it alone the better that idea is
little short so if you're going to try
to buy something in 12 months and you're
going to buy smaller rental properties
or something then I probably just use a
money market but if you think you're
going to play with this two or three
years because you want to buy a you know
a home similar to yours for rental and
it's going to take you two or three
years to build that up I might play with
an SP with it okay you kind of see the
difference but you understand you could
lose money doing right I mean it's a
it's not like insured or anything like
that and as long as you're willing to
accept a little bit of step back I don't
think you lose half your money and if it
was that low you just hold off on buying
real estate let the market recover okay
and you just yeah I'm not going to buy
right now but doing that I had built up
considerable funds and then when the
market turned down back in o8 man I
bought a bunch of real estate using
those monies out of that fund that I had
been chunking away because they were the
real estate was at a deal and you know
but but I moved some money out last fall
because I was getting I just bought a
piece of real estate and I'm getting
ready to do some building on it for this
company and so in you know and thank
goodness I did because it's down from
last fall so you're kind of playing a
little bit of a game there with that so
you you might want to split it and say
I'm going to do either none that way
because I can't take the risk or I'm
going to maybe put half of it in a money
market no it's not going to make
anything but I'm not going to lose
anything the other half I'm gonna play
with it a little bit see if it'll come
on up and make me a little bit so is
that all logical yeah
nonsense but you guys are cut to great
you're just rock stars you don't need me
man you're just you're so on fire this
is awesome
congratulations an honor to meet you Wow
very very cool
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
I want to write a song I want to own my
own business
I want to make more money those aren't
goals those are wishes my New Year's
resolution is to make more money this
year to wish